we're going to begin with this where the
stage is set for two historic elections
in November after last night's primaries
in Arizona and Florida the Florida
governor's race will have a supporter of
President Trump running against a limo a
Liberal Democrat who's called for his
impeachment Andrew Gilliam is the first
black candidate for governor to be
nominated by a major party in Florida he
will take on Rhonda Sanchez who came
from behind in the GOP race after the
president endorsed him in Arizona to
Congress women won their Senate
primaries Republican martha mcsalley and
democrat kristen cinema arizona has
never elected a woman to the Senate the
results followed a warning to
evangelical leaders from the President
on Monday he reportedly said if
Republicans lose control of Congress in
November
Democrats will quote overturn everything
that we've done and they'll do it
quickly and violently that'll keep us
here with the election results heed good
morning good morning the results of
Tuesday's primaries laid the groundwork
for some fierce fall show downs that
could very well signal how two big
states will swing in the 2020
presidential election despite being
outspent by tens of millions of dollars
Tallahassee mayor Andrew Gilliam pulled
off a surprising win Tuesday night in
the nation's largest battleground state
the 39 year old Gilliam is backed by
senator Bernie Sanders and other
national liberal groups if he wins
Gilliam would be the state's first black
governor everybody needs to support Ron
DeSantis Gilliam will face off against
another 39 year old trump backed
Republican congressman Ron De Santis
and we'll keep Florida great and we'll
make it even greater
Santis a Navy veteran credited the
president for his primary victory I did
have support from from someone in
Washington if you walk down Pennsylvania
Avenue he lives in the White House with
the pillars and
President Trump tweeted it was such a
fantastic win for Ron de santis and the
people of the great state of Florida
tonight marks the chapter the next
chapter in this campaign meanwhile in
Arizona Republican establishment
favorite congresswoman martha mcsalley
won a contest between candidates who all
tried closely aligning with the
president this is how I see this
campaign it's a choice between a doer
and a talker mcsalley was the first
woman to fly combat missions for the Air
Force she will run against Democrat
Kyrsten Sinema to fill the seat being
vacated by retiring Senator Jeff Flake
whoever wins will become the first woman
to represent Arizona in the US Senate
now that Arizona Senate race is one of
at least six all-female Senate contests
being held across the country this year
and we should point out that in Florida
outgoing Republican Governor Rick Scott
won the Republican primary to face
incumbent Democratic Senator Bill Nelson
we expect that to be the most expensive
race of this cycle it's always very
interesting employment thank you very
much